ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States well you
knew what you signed up for but thank
you for your service
okay bye Melania mr. president how do
you respond to the judges rejecting yet
another travel ban I reject their
rejection it's total fake news but Sir
people are calling it your biggest
public failure you're the biggest public
failure I decide how big my failures are
and they're the biggest wait that's not
what I meant
sometimes I get so frustrated that I
don't know what to do so I just raised
time I mean these reporters are so mean
to me why can't they be like my Fox and
Friends like Steve Doocy
and Bryan Ducey and lady duty and the
other idiots who say when I tell them
easy Donald you're the King time
how do you respond to Senator McCain's
implication that you're in bed with
half-baked spurious nationalists I don't
respond McCain is not my friend
and you know who else isn't my friend
NFL players military widows Hawaiian
judges Hawaiian pizza everyone in the
White House that me to hashtag and you
people yeah we're not your friends yeah
I said it first you're not my friends
but I want them to be and that's why
tonight's theme is friends they're
supposed to make me feel big and strong
and big well I make them feel small and
dumb and small that's what friends are
they're there to serve me this is my
castle and I'm the queen I mean the King
time seriously sir you never talk about
the good things I do good
I made the stockmarket a very big number
I made jobs that people have big jobs
Steve Jobs but he's dead but that's not
my fault that happened during Obama and
he didn't even call what are you talking
about what am I talking about
I don't like the way I feel right now
they made me feel bad about myself so
I'm gonna make them pay I'll make them
pay big time believe they um we can hear
you god damn it I forgot to do the time
thing whatever
I'm the king you're the president can
you believe it let's roll